[Music]
sophie turner just detailed her first
date with joe jonas and it is everything
it's great it's wonderful the 24 year
old game of Thrones star opens up about
those early days in ELLs April issue
revealing that as a team she wasn't
exactly lovesick for her now hubby's
boyband quote my friends and I were not
Jonas Brothers fans damn she just said
it straight up
not a fan no sugarcoating here people
sophie explained that at the time she
and her friends were super into a UK
band called busted who had a hit song
called year 3000
[Music]
well the Joe Broz covered the song and
made it a smash then busted broke up but
we thought it was all the Jonas Brothers
fault
so we hated them so years later when Joe
slid into Sophie's DMS asking to hang
out while he was on tour in the UK her
friends thought it was hilarious
and told her she had to go quote I
expected him to show up with security
and everything I thought he's gonna be
such a who else is living for this
candid confession well it gets even
better Sophie says that when she met up
with Joe she brought all her rugby guy
friends with her that's what we call a
power move and I like it the two met up
at a local tea bar with great music and
people throwing up everywhere because
all fairy tales start with once upon a
time at a local tea bar okay maybe not
all fairy tales start that way but this
date definitely had a happily ever after
because Sophie admits she was pleasantly
surprised by Joe who for the record
didn't bring security quote we talked
for hours and hours and hours and I was
like not bored
it wasn't contrived it wasn't small talk
it was just so easy and soon we were
like inseparable I went on tour with him
now it's nothing but love the pair had
two separate weddings one in Las Vegas
and one in France and Sophie says being
married has given her this incredible
sense of security and two awesome
sister-in-laws priyanka chopra who is
married to nick and danielle Jonas who
is married to Kevin quote it's also nice
to have built-in girlfriends who are
actually really cool who I can hang out
with and we can really talk to each
other about like how crazy the boys
lives are it's like we're all one big
family because the boys are best friends
how they helped you guys as a band the
dream came true
Sophie's Elle interview took place
before news broke that she is reportedly
pregnant with her and Joe's first child
but the couple has yet to confirm the
baby chatter of course you can count on
ET to bring you all the latest on Sophie
and Joe so make sure to keep it locked
right here until next time I'm Hallie
Stephens
you soon